hey everybody welcome to live coding
with Jesse I'm Jesse and today we're
gonna be working with react again and
lately I've been working through all the
issues in the github repo the links in
the description if you want to check out
that repo and I think we're just gonna
continue on with that today
so last week we did and the we check out
the the latest on the repos here I think
we worked on that jobs component yeah
yeah I think we did that so I don't know
that we got to add entirely finished so
maybe we'll finish that up and then
we'll move on to something else
so I think that was issue one number 107
yes we'll start out with that let me
switch up my screen over here and I'm
gonna check the live chat quickly before
we get started we got a few questions
right off the bat guru says q please
explain the header customize for
different devices there's a sidebar a
drawer and links in the app bar or
welcoming to other devices app are links
move to sidebar also explain multiple
menus in sidebar oh yeah so the the
header is just CSS so it's just media
queries so it just detects the width of
the screen and when the width of the
screen is small it hides part of the
part of the markup there
when it's larger it shows it okay so
those are just media queries and then
the sidebar menu which let me get a
browser window over here so we can see
it so we got a localhost I think I have
it running
I had it running did that break
something
it works so that side drawer it just has
collapsible so there's a collapsible
component that comes with material UI so
we've just nested those collapsible
elements within within the different
menus here so certain of these options
are collapsible right so that allows us
to go pretty deep with the navigation
without being overwhelming you know at
first because most of it is hidden and I
think we've done streams on on how we
built that so if you want to like really
detailed like how we coded all that you
know check back on some of the streams
when we were you know doing the side
drawer subtypes oh sorry about the yarn
I think sometimes we would title the
stream to a bar or things like that all
right let me I see that there's a little
bit more in the chat but I want to go
ahead and get started and then after our
first Pomodoro session I'm gonna come
back and answer some things in the chat
so hello to everyone who's please in
here now but let's let's get started on
this so I have a Pomodoro timer on one
of my other screens and I'm going to
start that a 25-minute session and after
that 25 minutes we'll do a little
question in the answer and and we'll go
from there
Bogdan said he looked shattered me I
don't know why I feel really tired and I
my eyes like look really tired oh no I
should Jin had more caffeine before we
started okay so we're gonna start with
that jobs component
so let me close out some of these tabs
and we don't need right now here we go
we're gonna do this job list because
that's what the last thing that we did
work on and see if we have yeah let's go
let's see what we have on the screen
first
I think that was HR and then yeah yeah
okay now I remember this
there's several URLs now that we have
set up that will take us to the same
page and what we what we were planning
on doing was adding some filtering but
you know what I think I don't know why I
didn't realize this last week but but
realistically you know we rarely have
more than 10 job listings at one time I
don't think that that justifies spending
as much time as we would need to spend
on all this filtering and building the
UI for the filters because if there's
only let's say ten or less jobs that's
not really a lot to scroll through so I
say we put that on hold and that could
be one of the things that can be done at
some point after launch and what we need
to do right now then is just work on
basically two things one we need to
include a little bit more info so if
we're not going to have a the property
have this be sortable we should at least
let people know if possible like what
department this is in although I don't
know that we have all the data for the
different staff departments we do for
faculty departments but then we should
let them know whether or not it's a
faculty or staff job and then also we
need to have some way of taking
something off the list so you know a lot
of these jobs they're not open anymore
so we don't want to list them so I think
it's probably worthwhile to have a
keeper listing at least for a while you
know in our database but we don't want
to have it be visible so that might
simply be you know going into WordPress
and switching that over to a draft
instead of a published post you know
maybe that'll be the easiest way to do
it but what to think about that but
first things first let's just clean this
up and let's make this look you know as
good as we can make it look without
spending too much time on it
so in the component itself I think
everything is is okay for the for this
job list AAS component yeah so at this
point well we can make it a choice here
do we want to make another component for
these individual job listings or not I
believe we had talked about modifying
our faculty was it our faculty list yeah
you know what we ended up we did make a
job list I thought we made a jobless
component alright so since we made a
jobless component I don't know I'm sorry
for some reason I was thinking we had a
component but maybe we don't you know
for now let's build it out here we'll
see how big it is if it seems like it's
way too big and we should move it to
another component we'll do that but
let's not optimize prematurely okay so I
am gonna leave this up though and
actually this might be too small for you
oh I'm sorry I'll make it a little
bigger here I'm gonna leave this up just
so that we remember what our structure
is to get data and let's see what else
we can get out of here so right now all
we're doing is just displaying the job
title but we should display let's see so
we have faculty departments or staff
department
let's go into our WordPress installation
and add in some data for this because we
need some data to be there for us to see
how it looks and right now we don't
really have any so it's fine where those
jobs are and I'm just gonna open up the
first couple of these just so we can get
some data
okay they did show up all right so
accounting clerk this is a staff job and
since we don't have a large staff
departments filled out here I'm not
gonna worry about that right now this is
operation support clerk it's also staff
job let's see what this one is faculty
secretary even though that's a faculty
secretary that still falls under staff
so faculty would just be strictly
professors online enrollment counselor
that's a staff job and then that's also
admissions so we can actually we can
click that one okay so it looks like
we're gonna have mostly staff jobs
except this one was faculty and we
already set that up so at least we have
those those all set up now and let me
close out of most of those all right now
we'll have a little bit of data to work
with and we can go through now and grab
the data that we need but what we also
need to do is make sure that we check
first because we could definitely get
errors here because sometimes if there's
no data this is just gonna be completely
empty so we can't just try to find
what's there because we'll get an error
if you let's say there are no staff
depart there's no staff Department
selected or something like that so let's
go through
we're gonna have to do everything within
this component here and I think that
what I'd like to do is maybe make a few
constants to make this look a little bit
a little bit cleaner we could we could
put our checks you know inside our
component but it's gonna make our markup
look messy so let's do let's do it like
this so what we're gonna do is put our
curly brackets here and so normally we
can it's just an arrow function just
Auto returns anything so if it was all
in the same line you wouldn't even have
to put anything you could just return
what was there or you can put
parentheses which is usually as
recommended if you do multi-line things
just so you more like readability I'm
not even sure it's 100% necessary but if
we want to start putting in variables
and things first we need to put these
brackets in there and then we also need
to return so we we need a return
statement now out of this whereas before
you know we didn't need that return
safely so let's copy this inside here so
we're still gonna return the same thing
for now we're just gonna make a few
variables and we add it in an extra
paren so we're gonna take one out so
we're even down there but then now what
we can do here is as we're looping
through all of the objects in this jobs
data array now we can pull out pieces
okay so we're gonna do const we'll call
this const this
yet we'll call this category and then
we'll do another one we'll call this
department launch department okay so for
a category what we need to make sure of
is like what at what point do we need to
stop and check to make sure something's
there so if you're not sure what I'm
talking about right now it'll make sense
once we actually get this going so for
now we can go and use this tool that
we've been using pretty frequently which
I have been calling what do I call it
I've been calling this graphic UL but I
watched the YouTube video recently where
someone called it graphical which now
makes a lot of sense so let me know in
the chat I'll learn in the comments do
you pronounce this graphical or graph e
qo obviously the term graphical makes a
lot more sense cuz that's like a real
word so so now I feel a bit silly but
it's always hard to know how to
pronounce things when you just see the
spelling and you never you never hear it
okay so this is not updated data this is
from the last search that I did but this
will be better for illustrating the
point since we have so much data missing
so we go in here and our first like if
we were to be looping over this right we
go data jobs edges okay so this is the
array we're looping through here this
edges array and then the first object in
the edges array is this object here so
let's zoom in so we just are dealing
with this one object first so we go to
this one object we go to node and then
within that that node we can see
we have job categories edges and then
edges in this case is another array of
objects so if we wanted to select this
we would say edges zero and that would
give us this one and then we could go
dot node dot slug right and that that
would work but if we went down here and
we did staff departments dot edges dot
dot edges 0 dot node right there is no
node right we're gonna get an error so
we can't just say ok like let's let's
get these in a straightforward way so
what we need to do is have some sort of
check to say like ok we can see edges do
we want to check and say if edges dot
length is greater than 0 then do we go
forward you know maybe that's what we
want to do ok so let's try that check
first because it looks like based on the
structure as long as edges has a length
of greater than 0 that means there's
something in here and so we should be
able to get the data then so that's the
first check we're gonna go with so
here's what we're gonna do we so since
we're already in let me show you so from
our perspective this has already been
done
right now we're strictly in here right
so when we look in here that first array
is called job I'm sorry that first
object is called job so we need to go
job node job categories and then check
the length of edges right so john node
edges
dot length is greater than zero so if
the length of that of edges is greater
than zero we're gonna do a little
ternary here so it's like like a little
if statement so if it's greater than
zero then let's let's go ahead and get
that value so let's go job node edges 0
dot node dot one was a slug got slug
okay now if it's not we want to return
[Music]
will should return I don't know
false
let's return false we're gonna do
something similar for Department and you
know maybe we should do we should split
it up and say like faculty and staff
Department right I week we could
probably do it so that we could check
for for either one right in the same
constant but I don't I don't really want
to I think that would look kind of
complex and I don't mind adding one more
constant in here so I'm just gonna take
this and copy it and we're gonna do the
same thing
let's see whoops I forgot job categories
didn't I yeah it's a job node let's go
jog all right that was lowercase there
we go all right so I'm assuming somebody
caught that in the chat so sorry I
didn't look down at the chat but okay
oops and I only did it for that lower
one did not do this all right great
since job categories we want to do the
same thing down here for faculty
departments okay faculty departments and
then down here we'll just copy and paste
that and change faculty to staff okay I
don't know why I'm trying to work with
this tiny space we really don't need any
of this other stuff right now okay so
now we have constants for category
faculty Department and staff Department
if these are present they will these
will end up being strings if not they'll
just return false so since we have that
now we can go down here and display our
our information so the first thing we
want to display and maybe we'll do it
let's do it like this will style it in
the minutes this is not gonna look great
for now
so let's just do a span and we're gonna
use dangerously set enter HTML inside
this band and we're gonna say category
and I guess
yet I'm kind of interested to see
because I know some of these we don't
even have a category for I'm interested
to see what this will do if it returns
false if it freaks out then throws an
error then we'll we'll need to put a
check here to make sure category is
actually a string and not false
otherwise I'm hoping that if we try to
put false in here it just won't render
okay so we'll test it with this first
I'm not even sure what a span will
display as hey there we go okay so
evidently it actually displays false aha
so we definitely need to change that so
let's see I wonder if we can put the oh
you know we can just do it like this so
let's say category and
all right so what this will do is just
say if category so that means if
category exist if it's not false then so
it's just going to do the rest of it
right so it's sometimes called I think
like a short circuit I don't know they
call it a short circuit operator but
anyway it's just a little shorthand way
instead of doing everything for a
ternary you just do that so let's make
sure What's it telling me I think it's
just spacing so I think this is fine
it'll work load there we go okay cool
so it worked so now this is only
rendering if we happen to have the
category present which I wonder why we
don't have staff present I thought we
did put stuff in yeah and I updated it
interesting
there we go okay so those updates we
made are they're wonderful so you know
we can add in a few a few things here
like see if we can do this inside is
that a function I think it is I mean I
know you can do it I just I can't
remember if you can do that in
JavaScript yep you can okay and we could
have done we could have done this in CSS
anyway I didn't explain what I just
meant I I mean I know you can do it in
JavaScript but I didn't know if that was
the syntax that they clicked so um all
right cool so we're gonna do a similar
thing for down here and here's what
we're gonna do though we're gonna say
this is gonna be a bit more tricky so
I'm sure there's gonna be more than one
way to go about doing this but here's
what I'm thinking we'll try first
so if faculty department or staff
department
back department or stats department and
you can't Nestor Nerys can you
I don't know if you can nest on it yeah
alright let's take it back take it back
a bit here's what we're gonna do
alright so if faculty department then
we're gonna say faculty if there's a
faculty department and then we are going
to display it and then if there is a
staff department we're gonna display it
all right so this is one of those times
where it's like first step is make it
work right cuz there's probably a way to
do this without the repetition that we
have here all right so let's see oh yeah
there we go
okay so we see it's saying nursing and
admissions so this is where you have the
department but let's see how do we want
to do this
I don't I don't like that I don't like
having the top and the bottom so here's
what I want to do instead let's make it
so that
all right so let's see if we have this
then
all right let's do this
what I want to put in is just a let's do
this for now this is going to look weird
[Music]
gonna do that we're gonna have a nested
span
alright let's see how this loose
okay so we have that there but I
definitely want I want a space to put
the space
see if this will work this is this code
is starting to look not so great
all right cool it works
I don't have used caught what I just did
I wanted there to be a space in here so
I just put in right we dropped into our
curly brackets here which drops us into
JavaScript but then I just wanted to
return what a space right so that that
works now what I want to do is take
these and render these up here yeah
let's render them up here first and see
what we get basically what I what I want
is them to be right after this faculty
thing here yep all right that works cool
so really basic not sure this is what I
want to go with you know for for sure
but that basically tells us this is a
faculty position in the nursing
department right cool does that make
sense then I think this is cleaner than
having it at the top and the bottom okay
and then obviously to clean this up a
little bit more wood I'd like to do
first let me check on the Sam out oh no
my timer went off I didn't even know it
all right let me go back to the chat
right now and answer some questions and
before I get too far ahead oh yeah I
went way over on my son oh whoa aha code
normal sis I'm learning angular is
angular fine or should i reconsider
reacts
it really depends on what you want to do
if you want to get a job somewhere and
you know they use angular stick with
angular I I don't know I mean it it
really depends on your your situation
your preferences you you do see you see
job listings for both and react
definitely has more momentum right now
but there's still a lot of places that
use angular and build things with
angular I mean it's back to by by Google
so it's it's not like it's going
anywhere anytime soon hey Anna and asked
how I'm doing not too bad
actually I coded in my living room that
the rest of my family was gone so I
coded in my living room for a while this
morning's inside the Sun comes in
through the window so I was just kind of
like relaxing had the windows open
listened to the birds so that was kind
of kind of cool
through bit through off my schedule is I
didn't get my normal workout in in the
morning so I'm gonna have to do that
after after I stream but otherwise not
doing too bad how are you doing in
shelter Rovin says do you have to be
good in mathematics to study / work in
computer science field no not
necessarily it depends on what you want
to do there are definitely some areas of
computer science that require more
aptitude and skill with mathematics but
if you let's say you wanted to be a
front-end developer then I I don't
really use any upper level math you know
ever how so
and yeah that's that's another one are
those questions that it really just
depends on what you're interested in
code normal says I have to work with
single page applications with a lot of
forms let's say CRM good is react for
that type of web app yeah it can be I
mean you can definitely handle forms and
react we've done forms before it's not
it's different than how you'd normally
do a form but it's not difficult there
I'm really sorry about this name Aero
Lua ir e higher so I'm sorry I can't
pronounce that let me know how to
pronounce it let's pronounce it right
but ir e o l UW a says is this visual
studio it's visual studio code so oops
wrong way yeah so this is the visual
studio code or people call it BS code so
which is definitely different than
visual studio both made by Microsoft
though Michael creo says I'm a little
upset that y'all work on a graph QL
query without me sorry I'll make sure we
save all the graph QL queries for you
mad justices here says good morning good
morning how's it going
okay so michael says it's definitely
graphical okay I will do my best to
remember that and pronounce it correctly
hey JavaScript this here says hey what's
up having talked to well nothing just
working lots of work
I got this project that I'm working all
day on and then if you know when I try
to get time in the evenings I'm working
on this this balanced IO app which is
really really cool projects so I'm happy
to be able to work on it but it's taken
a lot
Michael krios talking about inline
fragments for graph QL okay yeah I
haven't I haven't tried in inline
fragments I will have to check that out
as well
Oh mad - you said to go see it thanks
for watching
whoa Nicky says fallout 76 will be set
in West Virginia no way
um if y'all don't know I am from West
Virginia I don't live in West Virginia
right now but I live close to it but I
was born and raised in West Virginia so
I'm excited I'm definitely gonna check
out the trailer to that later today okay
let me answer a few more questions since
I went over on my Pomodoro session I'll
go over a bit on the question and answer
session here before we finish this
component up
hey hard shits here how's it goin hard
[ __ ]
javascript is Jesse you can press f5 to
refresh they don't always have to move
the pointers and stop the browser yeah I
just it's just to have it I mean I know
that you can use the keyboard shortcut
but yeah I'll just need to force myself
if I force myself to use it for a while
then I'll remember it
I'm I've been so used to having the auto
refresh work that I never I never need
to manually refresh but when I'm doing
these streams the OBS uses so many
resources resources on my computer that
the auto refresh just takes too long I'm
not patient enough for it so I just keep
like spamming the refresh button so
anyway thanks to JavaScript it a horse
should ask the pom-pom broke so harsh it
made the Pomodoro timer that I'm using
right now you know the alarm definitely
works I just my headphones that are
plugged into my phone right now and I'm
listening Spotify to save some of the
processing power on my computer for the
stream so I have my computer volume
turned all the way down and didn't hear
the timer but yeah the timer I always
hear the timer from from Paul Paul
alright I'm gonna go back I got through
most of the questions I'm gonna go back
now we're gonna do one more problem into
our session and finish up some stuff
with this component so let's see okay so
we've got these listings now we are
listing whether it's faculty or staff
and if there is a department selected we
also list that if not it just doesn't
display anything there but this doesn't
look great so and it also doesn't have a
length
we want to have lengths to a page that
has some info so that's what we need to
add and we need to add in the link let's
do the link first cuz that's that's a
necessary functional thing and then
depending on how much time we have then
we can look at you know maybe switching
up you know how these how these look
your styling a bit okay so for our
length we can use where's our slopes I
know we're grabbing this look somewhere
and we're already using it yep
so we're already using for our key this
job node slug right and let's see we
need to check to see what what the
current website is using do we really
need to know we don't yeah I don't think
we do right cuz job listings expire so
frequently we don't have really have to
follow the old pattern but let's see
what they use if it's reasonable then
we'll use the same URL structure
if not we'll switch it up so let's go to
Franciscan dot edu slash HR and I guess
I could have gone into faculty openings
or something but this will be okay all
right so let's go into faculty openings
I do want to make sure I get a count
here so there's only two here let's go
to staff opening I said earlier that we
never have more than like ten job
openings at once so now I want to make
sure that was true
yep I think we have nine total actually
and this is interesting the clinical
nursing clinical instructor is actually
listed under staff openings that's crazy
okay let's go read more it looks like
it's just HR VP development all right
let's make sure that's really the
structure cuz that seems to me like that
could get a little okay alright so they
don't really have a clear pattern here
so what I'm seeing is for these
positions that are kind of like lower
down in the organization
it's the URL is HR slash staff opening
slash and then the name of the position
and usually with like a date tagged on
at the end of it
but for these upper-level positions like
vice-president it's actually HR slash in
this case VP development so a vice
president of development so they're not
included under staff in the URL
structure and then for faculty openings
I'm assuming that it's gonna be slash
faculty yes it's gonna say slash faculty
opening / oh okay yeah all right
interesting
yeah I'm not gonna keep those let's
switch it up and here's what we'll do
so let's look at our server for a minute
to see what we're doing with with these
types of things so let's find okay so we
already having an HR here we can go HR
and then faculty opening staff openings
and what else did we have careers yeah
so let's go let's have it be HR careers
so HR slash careers slash whatever the
job title is or whatever the slug is for
that particular job
yeah that seems more straightforward we
don't have to maintain this this
structure of multiple pages and things
for the different categories and we'll
keep it like that for everything and
since we're just saying careers from
from what I see from the old structure
is that somebody must have taken issue
with people higher up being counted to
staff or with faculty being counted as
staff or staff yeah it's amazing like
how much terminology like upsets people
and makes people like people get really
into this terminology I don't know if
it's everywhere but at a university is
for sure like well this person is a
doctor and this personally as their
masters so you can't call them this or
that like it's wild so anyway we're
gonna get rid of all that and we're just
gonna say careers and leave it at that
okay so let's make our route now what
we'll need to do is say so far page with
careers I just set up a route with three
things on it recently how did I do that
let me scroll through for a second and
see which one I set up I think I put it
up here up at the top okay
[Music]
that's not thought it was departments I
guess not
it wasn't for that I can't remember what
it's for I noticed her [ __ ] said
something about this object being really
long yeah it's getting really long and
that's what I mean I've been afraid of
that for a while now I hope out how long
this is this is getting alright so since
I can't find where I did this I'm just
gonna try to make this work right now
which I just lost my spot here
HR alright so we're gonna say HR if we
go to careers jobless so let's go with
the type all right so what we need to
pass along is so if we go to careers
it's going to render jobless as the page
don't want that right so we want to say
this is gonna be tough how am I gonna
handle this
I should hold on this thing hard she
says I will rewrite that surveyed aijs
file using SQLite or sequel Lite DB in a
PR if I a time sequel I tis a file DB
there will only be a DB sequel a file on
the root of your project
all right that's interesting I haven't
noticed any issues with this being too
slow and other the only issue I've had
is just it just takes a while to scroll
so I usually just use a search right so
I just find where I'm at but if it would
increase the speed I'm open to other
other solutions but anyway so here's
what I want to do for the page so I do
have it set up
I just need to direct these to the
single job page which did we already
create that let's see where's our pages
here
now we didn't even create it yet huh
yeah we need to do that but for now I
guess I'll just call it job job Jas
so what I can do is thirdly this will
work but it's not gonna be ideal is
gonna get a job so basically any time we
see that there are three yeah anytime
there are three parameters in that URL
it's gonna automatically go to thirdly
which is okay unless we have some other
places like some other instances in the
HR pages that have three then it's gonna
mess things up so I may have to rewrite
some stuff in the router or something to
deal with this or I'll just have to look
at my router a little bit more and see
if I've already dealt with it and just
can't remember
and then here under type we're gonna say
actually we don't need to worry about
type do we no we don't
we don't necessarily have to worry about
type since we have a custom query for
that particular part okay let's just
leave it for now we'll leave it that
leave this off we definitely will need
the ID though so so we already have that
default in there looks so the ID is
basically what's gonna tell graph QL
what piece of content to get so thirdly
he's gonna be
if I need to do it like that careers
what if I can just go with careers I
don't I don't I think about it this
should be fine this should just pick up
it should pick these up automatically
and send it to this component all right
that should work okay I spent a lot more
time on that than I anticipated but now
we can go back to our job list and we
can say that we are gonna add a link in
here there we go so let's make this a
link I'm gonna have to look up how I do
links cuz I haven't made one for a while
next link all right there we go
it's a link prefetch there we go
so link prefetch a true profile link so
that's not what we need right now what
we wanted to get is /hr slash we're
gonna use a template literal here so
we're gonna say /hr slash careers slash
and then we're gonna come in with
variable which will end up being for
this particular thing the slug so it'll
be job no slug
and down here we can end our links I
don't know what did I do
I think I got rid of the h2 accidentally
there we go
yeah it should be yes you were
okay
still getting a lot of weird red lines
here see if it broke yeah Oh links not
defined
all right so let's pull in link so we're
using link instead of an a tag so that
we can have some client-side routing
happening so there-there won't need to
be a page refresh
cool
okay so it did when we clicked it it did
take us somewhere else but of course
that page doesn't exist because we
didn't set that up yet so that is
working
I will definitely want to do Styles link
is gonna be
we're gonna do cursor:pointer for length
all right and so that way it'll look
like it's clickable and is it styles is
it classes class name class is created
okay
okay
let's make sure that that words
I remembered the this time to use to use
my refresh shortcut oops I accidentally
clicked it all right I need to put this
maybe I need to put it on the h2
there we go okay all right so now it
looks like it's clickable much better
okay so in terms of functionality this
does what it needs to do now it has a
list it gives us basic information and
it's clickable in terms of style it's
not great so that'll be the next step
which probably won't do on this stream
so my Pomodoro session is just about
over about three minutes and then I'll
go back and do some more question
answers Wow and I've got a lot of
messages from work let me check really
quick all right so those some of the
work messages are just about where we're
gonna go for launch
all right so I think I'm good I have
some work emails I'm I'm actually really
amazed by how many icons are across
itself my phone right now okay cool
nothing nothing urgent so
let me I'm gonna commit this now before
I forget whoops
and add it all your on CM so we're
adding a new feature and what we're
adding is category links to just okay
that works and there are no breaking
changes but it does affect an open issue
we're gonna say yes and what do we say
that was issue 107 I believe this issue
107 I can double check
yeah 107 so we're gonna say this is
regarding number 107
hopefully this passes everything it
always makes me nervous when it takes a
while yeah alright what did I do
each female entities must be escaped or
my 108
and one night scene this does not make
very much sense
I messed up something here sits freakin
out
indentation come on
oh I see
why would you tell me we're trying to do
it like this I don't think it likes that
I have these brackets out there
it's upset
[Music]
alright let's share this
if I can get it to work right now I'll
just answer some questions and then I'll
do it afterwards
all right let's grow up and yeah it
worked I got that saving just in time
all right awesome I'm gonna do questions
now
Wow y'all been talking a lot in the chat
I keep scrolling up trying to find where
I left off I think I found it the vibe
house says I correct me if that's the
wrong pronunciation but they say how can
I learn to develop progressive web apps
with react if I am new to react Jas I
would use something like create react
app to start out with because it's
pretty much ready to go to be a
progressive web app right off the bat
that would be the easiest way to get
started with it so just follow their
documentation as well and you know make
sure you're doing everything you need to
for it to be a progressive web app Eric
says I'm learning both react both rails
and react can you do a tutorial mixing
it so I have a full stack application
tutorial unfortunately I don't know any
rails so I wouldn't be the right person
to make that tutorial my wife is
actually learning rails and react right
now so maybe at some point she can do a
tutorial for that but if anybody knows
of a tutorial out there or if you build
something with rails and react please
let us know in the chat another error Oh
No oh just a timeout it's just timing
out because I have OBS running so it's
taking too long so I'll just run it
after the stream is over
flexy says are you good at drawing and
painting do you think I can be a
front-end developer without being the
greatest painter AHA yeah yeah for sure
I'm I don't consider myself good at
drawing or painting at all so that
doesn't really matter there are some
front-end developers that that are more
creative in that area and they can do
some design work but to be a front-end
developer you don't have to have any
artistic ability now that you know at
least in the traditional sense of
painting and drawing sculpting things
like that if you wanted to be a designer
it could be a lot more helpful though
but I don't know that it would be
necessary
Rolle hate says what's the deadline for
this project the deadline is kind of
fluid right now we had some self-imposed
deadlines that we push back for like
various reasons so there's not a set
deadline right now I would like to
launch it before the end of the month
I'm just not sure it kind of depends I
have some some other people that are
gonna help me work on the data that's
the date has really been the thing
that's taking up almost all of my time
the only time I work on react stuff
anymore is for the streams and the whole
rest of the time I'm I'm just pulling in
data and building out those routes so I
just work with the the node router that
we have and with WordPress data and
that's it and I'm hoping to get some
help with the data side of things and if
that's the case then I can start to move
really fast with finishing up the the
you know react stuff and the styling and
I think it could work but it just all
depends on how much it works out you
know if the people that are helping are
you are able to go through it fast they
don't have a lot of questions then that
would be great if it ends up that you
know they're not really like confident
in their skills and I have to take a lot
of time that to help them through it
I don't know maybe not this month so
definitely sometime within this month or
next month though I think it's very
reasonable and and I would be very
surprised if it goes longer than within
another month
oh man Michael creo says no offense
Jesse how could you tell the difference
between before and after fallout in West
Virginia yeah I mean they're all right
West Virginia is a very poor state I'll
give you that but it's also a very
beautiful state it has a huge percentage
of the state is covered in forests nice
there's a lot of natural beauty in the
state you know some of the cities are a
bit rundown not you know not that much
in terms of industry happening but you
know it just depends on where you're at
you know there's some place in West
Virginia that are pretty rough and the
poverty is like really really high
poverty rates so yeah but some places
look pretty bad
Christian asked about which shortcut are
you using forgetting cursor where the
other word was highlighted command B so
you talking about multiple cursors so I
can go like like that for me it's
command D that's what it wasn't Adam and
I brought over all the Adam keyboard
shortcuts when I switch to vs code so I
don't know if it is command E and if
you're on Windows I think it would be
ctrl D I don't know if it's like that by
default in Visual Studio code and it may
be different in other editors when I
don't like a song I keep pressing my
keyboard to skip ahead and forgetting
that I'm listening to these songs on my
phone
I'm glad you can't see me defend
so Michael says if they based it here in
Mississippi I'd ask the same question
hi Michael creo says hey a VP position
sign me up yeah go go Eddie you try to
apply I imagine it's gonna be pretty
tough for that spot
Harshit says is it necessary for the
site to have 100% URL backward
compatibility not 100% so in most places
yes but there are some areas where we
can change it so in areas where content
expires so for instance in events that
right now on the site they don't keep
events around they expire and then you
can't get to the URLs anymore so we
don't have to worry about those we also
don't have to worry about it in job
listings because they expire as well so
those two areas I'm not worried about
and then in the news I'm not gonna worry
about it because they're just too many
news posts and the URLs don't match up
with the slugs like as they got pulled
in from one database to the other so at
some point if we have you know maybe a
student worker who needs some extra work
to do they could go through and try to
make the slugs match up with what the
old URLs were but it's not a priority
for me those pages are rarely visited
glad to ask what editor I use Visual
Studio code
Harshad s asking shredder run Apache
bench on this and see the request for a
second yeah I don't have a patchy bench
installed right now I have been worried
about the speed of requests having to go
through all this so I did have an idea
to split this up into multiple objects
so that a request would never have to
search through the whole thing so I mean
that's still possible to do but if like
you know if you have an even better idea
than that I'm you know I'm definitely
willing to go for that
how cool Aniki says so some of the
locations in West Virginia that the
video game are going to be a set in is
Camden Park The Greenbrier
New River Gorge Bridge and West Virginia
University wow that's cool I I used to
live in the city that West Virginia
University is located in sits Morgantown
West Virginia so I live there for two
years and I've been to that too
Morgantown many many times for American
football games
Michael said I think you kids are
crawling around in the ductwork yeah my
oldest my so my my two sons have they
share a room and then my daughter share
a room although Cordelia always ends up
sleeping in in my room so she's not
really in there but anyway this my son's
room is right above me so if you hear a
lot of noise it's probably them like
jumping around and playing jeff says
practicing their ninja skills
probably
Anoop Singh says can we make and make
OLX like app with react yes I'm not sure
what kind of app that is so if you get
explain it to me a little bit more I'd
be happy to try to answer let's see our
ketose TV says it didn't know where to
ask this got my first real project I
learned react recently and want to use
it but don't know Redux gravity well
should I take the risk of simply using
expression jQuery now you shouldn't need
to use jQuery if you were thinking about
using jQuery to fetch data just use
fetch so don't use Ajax use fetch
instead so just check out the fetch API
if you have to fetch on the server you
can get you can get packages to help
fetch work on server-side and
client-side you can definitely use
Express though Express is used
frequently with react so yeah but
anything that you're gonna want to try
to do with jQuery you can already do
just with react so with the exception I
would say of like asynchronous calls
you're gonna want to use fetch
oh oh I see sorry I misunderstood so it
wasn't he wasn't talking about using
[Music]
jQuery with react it was using jQuery
instead of react yeah I mean that's a
tough thing it just depends on how
confident you are in your react skills
if if the project has if you have a
decent amount of time to finish the
project I would say try to go with react
and learn what you need to if it's a
very short timeline and you just need to
get it done then go with what you're
good at right now so that I mean that'll
be a call you'll have to make because
you you know you know your own skills
and your own timeline so yeah but I mean
I I understand sometimes you just have
to get stuff done so it's totally fine
you know if you got a we got a you
jQuery instead and then just try to keep
getting better at you react until you
get to the point where you know you're
you're faster with that then you are
with the jQuery that's exactly how I
went about learning react as well I had
kind of a mix between jQuery and reacts
until I could take that step and just do
you know straight react development
Andre says do you use Gatsby in projects
and do you like it I tried some stuff
with Gatsby I did like Gatsby but I'm I
haven't used it a lot not that there's
anything wrong with Gatsby it's just
this past project well I considered
using Gatsby I ended up going with next
I was more familiar with next anyway and
then this project has been going on for
a really long time I just haven't had an
opportunity to try out Gatsby again but
from what I did use of it it was it was
pretty nice michael says do you really
need users to know it's a staff or
faculty job probably not but I I think
like people at the university probably
faculty members will I had imagined
there would be some faculty members that
might be a bit upset that they no longer
have their own page for faculty listings
and so being able to have them quickly
tell like what's faculty in what staff
position is probably better so but I I
don't think it's necessary for the from
a user's perspective but I'm just trying
to avoid or have like an alternative
solution there that I think will
probably be acceptable or at least will
sound reasonable so if anybody alright
I'm gonna give you some insight into the
psychology of me trying to get people on
board and supporting my project so I
always assume there gonna be some people
that are gonna be opposed to something
that I'm doing like no matter what
they're not gonna like it
even if I explain it and I'm not worried
about those people but it making
consensus around a lot of the other
people who their minds are a little bit
more open to the ideas so if the person
that let's say doesn't want it to change
would strongly
object to not having a separate faculty
page I could say something like you know
this is gonna make things a lot more
simple for people to find jobs if
somebody were to accidentally go to the
staff page they might not even realize
that there are faculty positions and
since we're listing very clearly which
ones our staff and which ones are
faculty we no longer need the two pages
and it'll still be clear to the user
which one it is
possibly even more clear than it was
before that logic may or may not
convince the one person or it's a few
people that are really one at the old
way but all the rest of the people that
would be listening to that logic would
probably think yeah that makes sense
and they'd be on board and that's really
what matters because there's not really
one or two people together that could be
rail you know whole project or you know
unless they were like let's say the
president of the university or something
right
as long as majority the other people can
see the reasonableness of what I'm
trying to do that's enough to to keep
going with the project so that's usually
how I go into thinking about presenting
things and meetings and things like that
I just I try to think and identify like
who's gonna have these objections and
it's it's not how do I convince them
it's how do I convince everybody else
that my way is more reasonable and
usually more user friendly cost
effective and you know things like that
so I find that that works well otherwise
if you try to keep pushing the issue
with that one person you run the risk of
seeming like obsessed with one issue
right or and so that you end up looking
worse
to everybody else right I don't know if
that makes sense to you all but
sometimes you just need but you don't
need everybody on your side
you just need most of the people on your
side or the right people on your side in
an organization so that that's what I
usually try to do and I just always
assume that there that I'm not always
gonna get everybody on my side so it's
just a matter of like managing the few
people that won't be and so anyway
that's my that strategy has worked for
pretty much every project there there
may be only been one or two times where
I really had to implement something that
I didn't think was a good idea but you
know and we're talking over the course
of almost three years now so I you know
it's worked out fairly well
Aniki says also isn't faculty
technically staff I don't eat it
at a university it's it's a weird
situation where like faculty are in a
class all their own in terms of like
their compensation their hours like how
they're treated is different than the
rest of the people that work in the
university you know they can get like
tenure which is basically like a
guarantee that you won't get fired
unless you do something illegal nobody
on staff ever gets that right and
they're even weird things like if you're
a part-time faculty member that makes
you an adjunct adjuncts don't have
access to a lot of things but if you're
a part-time staff member you get a lot
more benefits and then then a part-time
faculty member would but if you're a
full-time faculty member you you get
more benefits than a full-time staff
member would in terms of when you think
about things like tenure and being able
to take sabbaticals and things like that
so it's definitely a huge difference
between faculty and staff what's
expected of them and how they're
compensated at least in the United
States it's like that I don't know if
it's like that in other countries
so he's saying extra Andre saying
there's an extra slash in length all
right let me check that up was that the
problem the whole time no that's not it
oh yeah job list they must have gotten
taken care of then the extra slash
John says I setup hey John thanks for
joining us and John says I setup vs code
editor to use the es lint RC to run
prettier on each file save it's amazing
behind says thanks Nikki yeah for sure
it's so awesome if you're not using
prettier check it out
think about using it like try it it's it
auto formats your code for you it's so
much nicer to not have to worry about
the format of your code as you're coding
it's just like you have this freedom to
just just get the code out there and
then you know like it's gonna be alright
everything's gonna be formatted the way
you want it no matter how messy you put
it in it's really cool
Carlos is here hey Carlos how's it going
Oh her she is asking about feedback on
components for a JavaScript AF UI
let me pull that up on the screen really
quick here so I'm gonna paste this in
the chat as well so y'all can check it
out
so harsh has been working on this
these UI components here so you know
check them out it's got some really nice
ones here like so anyway you know check
out the link check them out give some
feedback if you can I think it's I don't
know why it's not working
some of it just might be my my machine
being slow because we're running OBS
yeah but you can see a lot of cool
components UI components yeah so let him
know what you think if you if you get a
chance
Bharath says could you suggest any web
resources or books to understand the
best react.js file component structure
oh I don't really know myself I've
always just kind of stuck with the
structure that I've seen like in the
tutorials for whatever I'm using so in
this case it's next j/s I don't know I
guess I haven't even thought about file
structure for a while you know I just I
just do what I've been doing you know
that's interesting question yeah I
really don't know anything off the top
of my head if anybody else knows of
anything that can help please put it in
the live chat our ketose says thank you
for the answer I was recently working on
stuff using react and didn't really know
how to pass data from my express server
to the front end kind of how it works
with ejs or handlebars okay so you know
what try out next Jas because they have
a like a function that allows you to
pass things a little bit more easily
from front end and to do server-side
rendering or from the back in the front
end do server-side rendering so try it
out it might work for your use case its
react but it just adds a little bit of
stuff on to react so yeah I'm not sure
but it might be worth to try to just
check out the documentation and see if
it would if it would be a fit for you
are ketose also says might be a very new
question but is is that where Redux our
graph geo comes in which one do I need
to learn first yeah no it's not a new
question I don't think it is but so
basically graph QL think of graph QL
just like you would think of a REST API
okay you're gonna use graph QL is just a
way to query a database
right so it's just like making an API
call you're just using a little bit
different format than you would for a
normal REST API once you get that data
and you could if you want to use Redux
to store that data and to make sure it
gets to the right components you don't
have to use Redux though but if you had
a large project it could potentially be
beneficial to manage all your state and
all your data with Redux hopefully that
makes sense let me know if if it doesn't
if you need some more explanation see uh
John says are you just gonna take that
server JS file and shrink it to a dozen
lines of code it will call backend API
I don't doubt Archie could do it our
students work is always so impressive
but I know our shoot is very busy right
now with school and with side projects
and things so school needs to come first
I have Michael says I'm just hoping when
harsh eight codes the next Facebook
before he's eighteen that he remembers
us
if harsh it's eighteen and he's not a
millionaire in charge of his own company
by then then I'm gonna start my own
company and hire hard [ __ ] because he's
he is definitely an impressive coder
our ketose is asking about context react
context API I haven't used it myself yet
but it kept that could potentially be
used instead of Redux and might be a
little bit more simple to use yet Redux
is a bit tricky to learn at first so I
will say that if you can do it if you
can do what you need to in react without
Redux I think that's usually a good
thing bringing in Redux can definitely
help make a complex thing more simple
but if you're just dealing with simple
stuff it can end up making a little bit
more complex than you you need it to be
see
michael creo says you might want to stop
talking about your job now i don't know
was that when i was talking about my
meetings and stuff
okay Carlos says we were talking earlier
about using rails with react Carlos says
I would create an API and then use react
to fetch the data all right that makes a
lot of sense yeah and then I mean you
could build things out just like we're
doing use either graph QL or fetch to
get data depending on how you built your
back-end yeah that's a good idea
Kyle says how do you link graph QL with
my sequel well in this particular case
we've done it through a wordpress plugin
I don't know how you would do it
by default you know you'd have to build
I don't think you'd have to build your
own thing from scratch I'm sure there's
probably some sort of setup that's out
there are ready to do it I'm just not
aware of it but we wanted to use
WordPress for content management because
it would be user friendly for those
people who are going to be managing the
content so we use the WP graph QL
plug-in to be able to call that my
sequel database where all that wordpress
data is stored and send that to our
react project our ketosis thanks a lot
Jesse first time on the live stream
we'll definitely come back again
awesome awesome I'm glad you liked it I
glad glad it was useful two years so
yeah I'll definitely be looking out for
you in future live streams
Harshit says I will be 18 on December of
2019 all right so I got to start my plan
my plan to start my own company then in
hire hire you Harshit will have to have
to have everything ready by December of
2019
Shubham says what's the best way to
learn Redux I learned Redux from the
react Udacity nano degree Udacity react
nano degree
yeah so that's what I learned it I'm not
really sure if you wanted a free
resource so that's a paid program if you
wanted a free resource maybe check out I
[Music]
don't really know does anybody know the
best free resource for learning Redux
there's got to be something good out
there I mean I was thinking probably
west boss has stuff but I'm not sure if
it's free stuff or paid I don't know
see Heath says so what are we building
here now we just finished up with some
coding for the day right now I'm doing
some question and answer but we are
building a react site with that gets
data with graph QL yes so that's what we
were working with today we do have it
connected to my sequel database with via
WordPress and the WP graph QL plug-in
but we were just doing some you know
there's some basic component editing
doing a little bit of work with a custom
node router
qasas Thank You Jessie you're welcome no
problem Christian says Jessie wanna
wanna partner up
okay harsh it says there is a free
restore resource so West boss does have
a free Redux course so I haven't done
any of his courses but I've heard good
things about them so you may want to
check them out
Harshit says it's at learn redux calm Oh
Carlos just thought about free code
can't Redux lessons I didn't realize
that they had Redux on the new
curriculum okay awesome that's good to
know
I'm actually check that out okay Nikki
says Dan Abramov has a Redux course on
egghead and it's also good cool our Tito
says the thing I was working on was a
simple contact form after sending an
email or not from Express back and I
wanted to pass a message to my component
and changes state according to show
message okay cool yeah we're we're doing
some of that in some of the the previous
projects that we've done on the stream
so it's definitely possible with react
it's it's not it's not that difficult so
yeah you can definitely use react to
that
krishna says how do i get into the new
courses and free code camp
I think everybody's automatically in now
I think they switched it all over
correct me if I'm wrong but I thought
that's what it was and I think it's
learned free code camp torgue and gets
where they're at now okay
I've gotten through all the chat stuff
so I'm gonna finish up now been a
decently long stream thank you all so
much for all your help and I'll most
likely be streaming again tomorrow yeah
we'll probably be doing similar stuff
react component stuff so I guess until
tomorrow
have a wonderful day